[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADAM KOCH: G'day.
My name is Adam Koch,
and this is Reto Meier.
And welcome to This Week in
Android Development on Monday,
January 20, 2014.
Coming from beautiful
Sydney, Australia.
Over the past few
weeks, we have been
hard at work making Android
better, faster, and stronger.
And that means another
iOS lesson from Todd.
Is Todd ever going to run
out of his iOS lessons?
Dan Lavelle covers
his second PlayByte,
talking about getting your
app priced just right.
And Dan and Bruno
hosted Game On!
Talking about the Google
Play Games plug-in
for the ever popular
Unity game engine.
Magnus released two DevBytes.
The first introducing the
Google Drive Android API,
and the second
covering how to get
started developing quickly
using this new Drive API.
Neto covered
density-independent pixels
in his native tongue
of Portuguese.
Shifting to this coming
week, on Tuesday,
Nazmul has a new episode of
UX Design for Developers.
And Todd answers
my early question
that no, he will not stop the
constant barrage of Play Games
on iOS lessons.
Neto covers responsive
design, again in Portuguese.
And Tony covers what's new in
Android 4.4 KitKat in Chinese
and in Cantonese.
And that's all for this
week in Android Development.
My name is Adam Koch,
this is Reto Meier.
Tie me kangaroo down sport,
tie me kangaroo down.
Happy Australia Day.